à tahiti à présent en compagnie de jean
michel cousteau une association de
défense de l'environnement l'a invité
pour sensibiliser les jeunes à la
protection du corail menacées par le
réchauffement climatique comme par
l'activité humaine
il aura fallu des centaines d'années
pour obtenir 1 corail de bonne taille et
plusieurs milliers d'autres pour créer
un récif mais aujourd'hui c'est
magnifique d'écosystèmes sont en danger
depuis quelques années jean michel
cousteau fils du célèbre explorateur
jacques yves cousteau contribuer avec sa
fondation à promouvoir la préservation
de cette richesse maritime
aujourd'hui c'est au tour des enfants de
cm2 ont polinelli de bénéficier non
seulement de ces informations
mais aussi d'ateliers animés par les
bénévoles les jeunes il reste les jeunes
ils sont là on peut les retrouver et on
le voit grandir et ça devient des
décideurs les gouvernements ça change
tout le temps les jeunes
faut il faut arriver dans seulement
aller à les atteindre quand ils sont
très jeunes et ensuite à continuer à
leur donner l'espoir de manière à ce que
lorsqu'ils deviennent des décideurs
eux-mêmes qu'ils soient dans leur
famille dans leur métier et
éventuellement peut prendre de
meilleures décisions
en effet les jeunes générations ou doit
déjà faire face aux conséquences des
décisions prises par les adultes de la
survie des coraux l'échauffement
planétaire en passant par la pollution
sous toutes ses formes
c'est à chacun aujourd'hui de faire un
geste pour l'environnement